What's up?
>> What's up, bro?
>> Yo. Um, I'm listening, bro.
>> Okay. What most What message do you
think Paul contradicted?
>> What was that, brother?
>> Peace to you as well. What uh what
message do you believe Paul corrupted or
contradicted?
>> I honestly just can't grasp the concept
of like the trinitarian triune kind of
thing. Um, I think it's too complicated
for for me to understand.
>> Does that make it false?
>> Not necessarily. Um, but I I do
commandments and I believe one of the
commandments was like one God, you know,
and it makes sense for God to just come
back and tell you that, you know, come
back to my old my my true ways and
worship one true God.
>> You've read the commandments before?
>> Yeah. I mean, I read some parts of it.
>> So, you haven't So, you haven't read You
just It sounds like you're kind of going
off what you heard. You haven't like
investigated this yourself?
>> In a way, in a sense. I mean, kind of
collecting data through um, you know,
certain things. I've heard the triune
god was like pagan and stuff like that.
I hear. I see. So you believe that Paul
contradicted the message that of the
Torah like the Old Testament. Is that
what you're saying?
>> Like the Ten Commandments. Yeah. Like I
mean cuz cuz like the idol part, you
know what I'm saying? You shall not have
like idols and you shall not have no
other guys before me. I feel like
there's like a lot of partners. If you
guys were just worshiping the father,
maybe that would be accurate and then
that would have got abrogated later on
into Allah later on and then you guys
would have maybe adapted it. But the
thing is literally you guys are
worshiping all three in one which makes
it completely pain and you guys
associate partners.
>> I'm I'm a little I'm a little I'm a
little confused. Hold on. Slow down off
man. Slow down. I'm I'm a little
confused. So um so you're saying that
Paul contradicted the message of the Old
Testament in which there is only one
God. Um
>> Mhm.
>> That's that's what literally what Paul
says. He says there's only one God.
>> Well Paul says there is three in one
God. The the what? The father.
Can you show Can Can you show me where
Paul said that?
>> Yeah, I can try to. So, you're telling
me you worship only one?
>> Yep.
>> Well, the thing is though, like it's not
necessarily how would it be one if
there's like different parts of bodies
and stuff like that.
>> I think you should ask yourself that
question. You believe that Allah has
different parts of his bodies and stuff
yet you believe he's still one God. I
don't believe in partialism. You do. You
condemned yourself just now.
>> Well, yeah. So the part with partials is
that would be considered his like
basically his characteristics and stuff
like that. We don't attribute those as
like independent um type of things like
independent body.
>> He has he has he has hands, he has feet,
he has a face,
>> but it's not parts though.
>> Those are parts. Is Okay. Is is he
identical to his hand?
>> Well, yeah, of course. I'm saying that
he has a like like he has a he is a
deity. So he obviously has a some sort
of like
>> is Allah shape.
>> Is is Allah his hand? Well, that's what
is described, I think. Yeah.
>> Is he his hand, though? Is he identical
to his hand?
>> No, no, no. He's not identical to his
hand,
>> right? So, then it's a part of him. He's
not identical to it.
>> It's a part of course, but it still
makes him one.
>> All right. So, all of these different
parts come together and make him one
composite being, one composite God. So,
you believe in parts.
>> Okay, I can get I Okay, I I can get
where you're going with that. Um, so
it's not necessarily that it is actually
three. It's actually just the three
different roles playing on into one type
of structure kind of in a way. I believe
I believe in one God. He's not divided
into parts. He's there's no partialism
in him. He's not divided. He's one God.
>> I just can't grasp that though because
the three
>> but how could you grasp God having
having actual hands and feet and stuff?
How can you grasp Can you grasp that?
>> Well, of course, because ultimately if I
were to think of him as only one being,
then I would think of him inside of that
physical aspect. But I wouldn't consider
him because because the the the two
other roles play a part and disapparts
and disassembles from the father. So I
wouldn't understand.
>> I want you to I want you to take really
consider what you're saying. You're
saying that you can grasp the Islamic
concept of God. Like that's something
you can understand. You can picture it
in your head. You can grasp it. You can
understand it.
>> When it comes when it comes it's okay.
It's okay. When it comes to the trinity,
the trinity is a concept of God that you
just simply cannot grasp. And so I want
to give you this perspective. Um when
you have God according to even the Quran
and the Bible, God is stated to be
unlike anything in his creation.
Correct?
>> Yeah. Of course, he's outside of the
creation.
>> So we as creatures because he's
completely other than he's outside of
creation, we cannot comprehend him,
right?
>> Yeah. We cannot comprehend or fathom
him. Yes.
>> Or fathom him. But notice what you said.
You said that you can fathom your God.
You said you can grasp, you can
comprehend your God, but you can't
comprehend or grasp or fathom my God.
So, which one of our theologies fits the
bill?
>> That's a good question. That's that's a
good question.
>> Um,
okay. Let me try to answer this in the
best way possible.
>> Um, so, okay. So, you're saying that
Okay, so your concept of of what? Let me
ask you this. So what is your concept
then of Jesus Christ that happens to be?
What did it happen to be? A man that has
uh physical parts.
>> My concept of Jesus Christ is that he is
God who and he's the second person of
the Godhead. He's the son, the word of
God who took on flesh, right? Took on
the nature of humanity and walked
amongst us. That's my concept of Jesus
Christ. Okay.
concept.
>> With this being said, this is something
that again, my concept of God meets the
criteria of God being incomprehensible
and unfathomable. Infathomable,
you know what I'm saying? Uh while the
concept of God in Islam is
comprehendable, is graspable. You can
you can fathom him.
>> Yeah. So I think that if you're putting
that in in perspective, the the
Christian God, the Christian theology
matches who God would be more so than
Allah does.
>> Okay. Well, just I get what you're
saying just because interesting. I guess
it's very interesting.
>> We should not there should we should not
be able as you said and as our both of
our scriptures say we should not be able
to point to creation and say see God is
like that. I can understand that or see
this reminds me of God like that that is
like that in regards to his nature, his
essence. And so when it comes to the
trinity, we cannot point to anything
that has one essence and yet has a
plurality of persons or hypotheases
within it. There's nothing we can point
to that we can say, "Yeah, like that."
Or, "Yeah, like that." We can't.
>> But with Allah, we can do that. Well,
with Allah, we also don't um we we just
Okay. We he also has characteristics
like also like like because his 99 names
also carry a lot of uh characteristics
and a lot of his attributes or whatever
and whatnot. So the the so which is
really strange. So we it's not that we
disassemble them in parts though like
you said that we feel like the
trinitarian doctrine is dis
disassembling it in parts and we don't
do that. we necessarily grasp the
concept that he is one with ultimately
infinite uh springs of knowledge,
infinite springs of information that
could be um coming from within his
source. You know what I mean? So, but
this is this is my thing when you say
like you know you talk about Allah's
hands, his shin, his feet, his face and
all these things, right? These these
body parts are not identical to each
other. These are different than one
another, right? The shin is not the
face. the hands are not his foot and
yada yada yada. So these are different
body parts of Allah of how he describes
himself and it's not metaphorical. It's
actually like this is what he actually
is. You know what I'm saying? And so
>> this this isn't like a lot of people
don't want to say this like Muslims they
don't want to say this. They want to
admit it but it is partialism. You you
believe in a God that is composite that
it's uni these are all things that are
unified into making Allah what he is.
You know what I'm saying?
>> So would that consider him not to be a
deity then? Because so would you
consider Jesus to be a deity?
>> Yeah, Jesus is God because he's
indivisible. He's not made up of parts
in in his divine nature. I'm not, by the
way, I'm not I'm talking before his
incarnation before he takes on flesh,
right? Just simple simply his divine
nature. It's not divisible. It's not
made up of parts. It's not split.
>> Okay. So, but what would you consider
the father to be then? Because if you
were to disassemble them and understand
who Jesus is, then who who would the
father's figure and his key role is? Is
he ultimately the one that has infinite
knowledge that comes out of him springs
out of him?
>> Yeah. So,
>> cuz like that's what I'm not
understanding because like
>> cuz like Okay, let let me try.
>> So, let me try.
>> It's it's almost as if there's a block
because of the two parts kind of telling
me like you know this is like the father
is almost as it's way greater than the
two others. So, how would that make it
even equal?
>> But what's what's telling you that?
There's also sources too that state it
too.
>> What what what what tells you that Jesus
is not let me just forget that. Let me
just show you what g what what Jesus
says here and what the Bible says. So in
John chapter 5, watch what Jesus says.
Jesus breaks down his distinction with
the father yet and his equality with the
father even though they're distinct in
person. He's not a separate deity, rogue
deity, divine guy doing his own thing.
But he's inseparable from the father,
equal with the father in his essence
while distinct from the father and
humble to him. So look, so for example,
um in John chapter 5, Jesus is healing
on the Sabbath. Okay, let me just uh
give you this context here. So it says,
"Now that day was the Sabbath." So the
Jews, I'm sorry. So Jesus just healed a
man on the Sabbath. He told the man,
"Get up, take your bed, and walk." He
was paralyzed. Right? So it says, "Now
that day was the Sabbath." So Jews said
to the man who had been healed, it is
the Sabbath. It is not lawful for you to
take up your bed. But he answered them.
But he answered them, "The man who
healed me, the man who healed me, that
man said to me, take up your bed and
walk." So they asked, "Who told you
this?" Right? Um and he and uh so it
says now the man who had been healed did
not know who it was for Jesus had
withdrawn and there was a crowd in the
place after Jesus was found after Jesus
found him in the temple and said to him
see you are well sin no more that
nothing worse may happen to you the man
went away and told the Jews that it was
Jesus who healed him and this was why
the Jews was persecuting Jesus because
he was doing these things on the
Sabbath. Now do you want do you know why
that's that's significant? Jesus doing
works on the Sabbath. Are you familiar
with the Sabbath?
>> Yeah.
>> Right. So, according to the Sabbath, the
Jews are not supposed to work, right?
They're not supposed to do any labor,
right?
>> Yeah. Of course, that's Saturday, ain't
it?
>> Yep. Exactly. That's a Saturday. Now,
Jesus though on the Sabbath is going
around healing folks and forgiving sins.
And so, they come to Jesus and says,
"You can't do these things. You can't be
working these miracles and doing all
these type of actions on the Sabbath.
It's the Sabbath." But Jesus says, it
says this verse 17, but Jesus answered
them, "My father is working until now
and I am working." Let me ask you this.
Why is it that the father is able to
work on the Sabbath?
>> So the father and Jesus are taking on
that role.
>> What role though? Why why what is the
role of God on the Sabbath? Really every
day? Why? Why does God Why does God get
to work on the Sabbath?
>> I mean, he's the Lord of the Sabbath.
>> Exactly. He's the Lord of the Sabbath.
But not just that because he he he
created the Sabbath. But notice
>> that's what you guys think though. You
guys think he's the Lord of the Sabbath.
>> Oh, well that's that's what he says. He
says that himself. Jesus says he's the
Lord of the Sabbath.
>> That's what it says in the Bible.
>> Yes, sir.
>> And so and here's this is why it's
significant. The father one, he's God,
right? So God continuously sustains all
of creation. His divine actions he
continues to do, right? No matter what
day it is, right? He's sustaining all of
creation. He's sustaining the universe,
the space and the galaxies. He's the
reason why all of all things hold
together as it is. It's because of him.
Because of God. Do we agree?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, if God were to stop doing that,
then all of creation would collapse.
Everything would collapse and die off,
right? But God is sustaining it even on
the Sabbath. So Jesus says my father is
working until now and I also am working.
So Jesus is saying he is able to perform
his divine prerogatives just like the
father is because they are the one who
sustain creation. So he makes himself
equal with the father. And this is what
it says literally. says, "This is why
the Jews were seeking all the more to
kill him because not only was he
breaking the Sabbath, quote unquote, but
he was even calling God his own father,
making himself equal with God." So Jesus
makes himself equal with the father by
saying that he's able to perform divine
um works on the Sabbath while at the
same time, you know, being distinct from
the father. this makes him equal with
him. So there's nothing that is saying
that the father is far greater than the
son. They're equal in their essence.
However, when it comes to their roles
and their operation, the son does humble
himself to the father and you know he
took some he took on the form of a
servant. So he humbles himself to the
father. So he's humble in one aspect,
equal in another. Make sense?
>> Okay. I guess I guess you're you're
describing his like attributes, right?
Yep. Exactly. So Jesus has the same
attributes that the father has. So does
>> how he wouldn't have had the same
attributes when he came down though,
right?
>> Yes. He has the same attributes when he
comes down. However,
>> so he would be all loving and all
merciful and every single attribute that
God had when he was down,
>> brother.
>> He would be infinite in knowledge. But
he said he didn't know the
>> infinite in knowledge. And yet the word
when he says that he's infinite
knowledge and no one knows, he's talking
about declarative knowledge, not
cognitive knowledge. There's a
difference.
>> Did it say that in the Bible? Did it
ever say declarative knowledge? I think
you just made that up, bro.
>> You think I did?
>> I mean, yeah. I mean, obviously, come
on. You just making [__] up at this
point.
>> Have you ever Have you ever watched any
of my content?
>> I'm just playing, bro. I'm messing with
you, brother. Hey, man. I I just I'm
sick and tired of the fighting with the
religions, man. That's That's the thing
I I just don't agree with. I just wish
that it was Man, I think I don't know
why God would not make a universal
religion and make it just all peaceful,
brother. Why do we got to be always
arguing against each other, [__]
reading new books and [__] I'm tired of
this [__] man.
>> Oh, so you were just a troll this whole
time?
>> No, I'm not a troll. I'm here to learn.
For real. We all learn in school anyway.
He He was just here trolling this whole
time, bro. Had no arguments as a Muslim
and then just wanted to troll after
that. What's up with these guys, man?
What a waste of time.